BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
SUSANNAH RAUB: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
RETO MEIER: This is where
the magic happens.
JENNY MURPHY: This is primarily
a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
NICK BUTCHER: We have
a recording.
NICOLAS GARNIER: We should
try to be very serious.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Yes, so I--
[LAUGHTER]
IDO GREEN: So we're here in
GDL IL, episode number
[INAUDIBLE], we'll see.
Later, in the future,
we will edit it.
So I guess--
NICK BUTCHER: It'll be
a loud voice editor.
Four!
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yes, exactly.
IDO GREEN: So we are lucky to
have with us people from the
Android team and Drive team.
Maybe we kick off with each
and every one of you just
presenting yourself?
NICOLAS GARNIER: Sure.
I'll start.
I'm Nicolas Garnier.
I'm a Developer Advocate working
on Google Drive, and
I'm based in Zurich,
Switzerland.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Hey.
I'm Richard Hyndman, a Developer
Advocate for
Android, based in London.
NICK BUTCHER: I'm Nick Butcher,
also an Android
Developer Advocate
from London.
IDO GREEN: Great.
And for the ones that didn't
know, I'm Ido Green, Developer
Advocate working now here
in Google Israel.
So maybe you want to ask the
people about what we're doing
here, why you came--
took the long, long
flight to Israel.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: --like
four hours.
How did we survive that?
NICOLAS GARNIER: Yeah.
So what are we doing here?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Why would
Android and Drive
be in a room together?
NICK BUTCHER: Exactly.
NICOLAS GARNIER: We came here,
and we're doing, actually a
bunch of different things.
The first thing is we're meeting
local companies.
And personally, I'm meeting
companies that are potentially
going to integrate with
Google Drive.
And I'm trying to see if
they need assistance.
Or trying to show them what are
the features, and how they
could use and integrate Google
Drive in their products.
I guess you guys'll do the same,
right, with a bunch of
different people?
A lot of the awesome start-ups
here in Israel that have been
working at the hackathon turned
up at the Afeka College
of Engineering, where we're
based for this couple of days.
IDO GREEN: So you came,
basically for a GDG event that
we had yesterday.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: So first
we met people.
And yesterday, there was this
nice event organized by the
GDG Tel Aviv, right.
IDO GREEN: Yeah.
NICOLAS GARNIER: And the
college here, Afeka.
What's the full name?
Afeka--
IDO GREEN: Afeka College.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Afeka college.
Good.
IDO GREEN: It's easy.
And I did a one-hour
presentation basically about
Google Drive SDK, and
Google Drive itself.
Just explaining how it
works technically,
what are the features.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: It was supposed
to be a one-hour
presentation.
Really [INAUDIBLE] one hour
thirty-some-odd presention.
NICOLAS GARNIER: It was suposed
to be 45 minutes.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE],
he was like, this is when my
presentation's supposed
to finish.
I'll take another
half an hour.
You guys?
Psh.
NICOLAS GARNIER: I was
like, oh shit.
I'm overdue over time.
I'm in the middle of
my presentation.
Well, screw it, I'm just
going to [INAUDIBLE]
IDO GREEN: Well guys,
just bear with me.
[INAUDIBLE]
slides.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Slide
29 of 100.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Drive is
so interesting, though.
You can't stop.
You just can't.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: The audience
was silent the whole time.
Just engaged.
Following that, we had a little
talk about Android.
I did the talk, and
so did Nick.
I was talking about
Android 4.1--
JB, API level?
NICK BUTCHER: 16.
IDO GREEN: Wow.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Testing.
Testing.
16.
API level 16.
And Project Butter.
Went into a bit of detail about
some of the new APIs in
Android 4.1.
The media codec.
All that lower-level media API
stuff, so you can inspect
media files.
You can encode and decode
using the hardware.
It's not so much fuss than
previous versions.
NICK BUTCHER: And after
Richard's low-level technical
goodness, I went completely in
the other direction, and
talked all about UI, and much
more fuzzy, hand-wavey topics.
So I talked about some of the
things that we see lots of
developers not doing so great.
Like, say, how to make an
application that's responsive
and friendly to use,
easier to use.
And especially how to make an
application feel Android-y.
How to make it feel right at
home on the Android, and not
carry over conventions
from other platforms.
And I talked in depth about some
new patterns that we're
seeing emerge.
So things like how to build
swipe-to-dismiss, which you
might have seen on your
phones, with the
notifications.
How to do rich notifications.
How to do some tricks with
scrolling, to make most of
your small area.
And I also talked about the
mindset you need to be an
Android developer.
Like how to think mobile.
How to design for the vast
array of small, large,
medium-size devices.
It was a great, great
audience.
They asked some really good
questions, and seemed to
really enjoy the content.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I thought you
were going to say, it was a
great, great talk.
NICOLAS GARNIER: It was
really awesome.
NICK BUTCHER: No, I'm not
going to say that.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I really
think you would.
IDO GREEN: I did an amazing job,
and everybody liked it.
NICK BUTCHER: But it might as
well be online [INAUDIBLE].
It was a good audience.
It was like 140 people turned
up for the GDG event.
There was a huge [INAUDIBLE].
IDO GREEN: It was actually very
surprising, because we
had about 170, 180
that registered.
And then usually, it's
like 60%, 50%.
And then the show-up was
really impressive.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
partly the falafel.
I think word's got out that
the falafel is very good.
NICOLAS GARNIER: [INAUDIBLE]
IDO GREEN: That's actually--
Michael did a really, really
wonderful job just organizing
everything.
We love coming to Israel because
the developer audience
is really, really super,
super sharp.
The questions you get when
people are pitching topics to
do in a hackathon.
There's some real
smart groups.
And some are really keen to make
things and ship stuff.
So it's really awesome to
come here and see that.
IDO GREEN: Cool.
That's actually really
interesting.
I wanted to ask--
I spoke with Nicolas before
about maybe you could
highlight two or three companies
that you worked with
that were impressive, and why.
What they did right, what
they could improve.
NICOLAS GARNIER: You mean today,
or in [INAUDIBLE]?
IDO GREEN: Yeah.
Just speak.
NICOLAS GARNIER: OK.
Anybody?
IDO GREEN: Yeah, sure.
NICOLAS GARNIER: So Microsoft,
they're really--
[LAUGHTER]
IDO GREEN: Netflix.
I like the service, but--
NICOLAS GARNIER: --you're
doing everything wrong.
I'm joking.
I love you, Microsoft.
Actually, right here, I've
met with [? Majisto ?]
and also [? Powtuns ?]
who are local companies
here in Israel.
And they are actually
integrating with
Google Drive today.
So we haven't sat
down already.
But there's a hackathon going
on today, where people are
trying to build Android
and/or Drive apps.
And these two companies have
started integrating with
Drive, and they're making
good progress.
It's actual products, with
lots of users already.
And they're integrating today.
Actually, [? Majisto ?] was
super-advanced already.
They have something pretty
much working.
So it's nice to get
real companies
engaged when you come.
And we actually met them
yesterday, right?
For example, [? Powtuns. ?]
And we showed them what the
Drive integration was like.
And they were like, cool.
We'll integrate.
We'll start tomorrow
in the hackathon.
And boom, they're doing it.
NICK BUTCHER: That's
philosophy.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: We've met with
a whole load of partners.
A lot of them have been
asking for UI reviews.
So you've got a niche
speciality there.
Especially partners
who have their
apps live in the Android--
well, in Google Play.
It was the Android market
at the time.
I don't need to [INAUDIBLE],
because it is valid.
They had it in the Android
market before we launched our
design guidelines.
So it was still there.
And obviously, the one UI
review-- because they had
their app launched before our
design guidelines came out.
And now we have design
guidelines.
They just want to know how to
really ship their app across
to make it into the new
Android look and feel.
And the ones that have done
well have already read the
design guidelines.
And they've come in, and just
said, this is what we're
thinking about for our design.
And that makes our lives
a whole lot easier.
It's very, very nice to see.
They just come back with
something that's
looking great already.
IDO GREEN: Yeah.
That's really cool.
And actually, we
should mention.
We put all the links in the
show, so people could jump on
and see exactly what
we have where.
Sure.
IDO GREEN: Because
of resources.
Yeah, absolutely.
IDO GREEN: Great.
Any other thing you'd
like to talk about?
The event, or new stuff that
we're going to have in the
near future?
I know that usually, we're not
making a spoiler-breaker.
But things that are we
can share with--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Well, when's
this going to be broadcast?
IDO GREEN: Two weeks from now.
So it's live.
NICK BUTCHER: We haven't got
any announcements tonight.
But some of the cool stuff I
highlighted is, for me, in the
Android world, I love the open
source contributions.
So many people take the patterns
we've introduced,
like on our design site.
And implements them
[INAUDIBLE]
and so on, so that they
can share them.
Like I said, I'll give a link
to the slides of the
presentation, which has more
links to a bunch of open
source implementations of stuff,
as well as a couple of
new things which came out
in the last couple of
days which I like.
Which is a few online
style generators.
One of the things I talk about
when I talk is how to take the
Android style, the hollow
themes we call it.
And customize it.
Use it as your base,
and marry that with
your product's branding.
So a few cool tools have come
out, like some online style
generators.
So you put in the colors and
look and feel that you want.
And it'll generate all the
image [? drawables ?]
and XML files that you need to
put into your Android app, to
make it have that
look and feel.
So those are some cool
tools to check out.
If you're following my Google +
profile, I've posted slides.
IDO GREEN: Great.
[INAUDIBLE].
Excellent.
Drive?
Drive had an announcement,
right?
I saw a [INAUDIBLE]?
I would just say there
was just [INAUDIBLE]
some quick start sample code--
Cheers.
NICOLAS GARNIER: --that
we've added.
Yes, well.
We do that every day.
That's perfect [INAUDIBLE].
[? I'm sure that's ?]
[? normal. ?]
So [INAUDIBLE] there's
actually quite a few
things coming up.
My boss has already leaked it
on [INAUDIBLE], so I can
totally talk about it.
So we're working on adding push
notifications to our API,
so you'll be able to register
a callback.
Whenever a file changes on
Drive, we'll let you know.
And you don't have to--
the other method was to pull
every minute or every hour.
So I could now sync between
my Android devices
using Google Drive?
Because every time I'd change it
on one device, sync that to
Drive, then Drive will
then invoke a
callback to push it through--
NICOLAS GARNIER: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: --somewhere
else.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Then Drive will
broadcast a callback to
other subscribers, and
they will know
that your file changes.
And the other big thing
that we're doing--
I can't go into many
details there--
But we're working on and
improving a lot, and changing
a lot the experience about
discoverability of Drive apps.
And making it way easier for
users to find Drive apps.
A lot of Drive apps
exist for us.
And it will allow the developers
also to get more
visibility-- a lot more
visibility, I expect--
for the app on Drive.
I see.
That, hopefully, will come in
the next couple months.
Two, three months.
Some big changes there.
IDO GREEN: Great.
Thank you very much
for your time.
Thank you.
That was very good.
We'll catch you later,
on the [INAUDIBLE].
We'll do the next episode.